today we've got to preview from the
latest chapter of the war of jokes and
riddles in Batman plus we're going
inside the first-ever box from DC's
world's finest subscription service so
get ready for DC all-access
[Music]
hey guys I'm Jason Inman and i'm hector
navarro put down your god killer shorts
people because we've got a rundown of
all the DC news you need to know you can
now invite the princess of famous kira
right into your home thanks to the
digital release of Wonder Woman Diana's
solo movie stood head and shoulders
above the competition with a magical
combination of action humor and heart be
sure to make the biggest movie of the
summer part of your permanent collection
on digital HD today it's time to dive
into the Scarlet speedster past and
rewatch the third season of the flash
remember when Barry caused flashpoint
and ended up fighting an evil version of
himself from the future well it's all in
the blu-ray and DVD release of season
three so settle in for an epic binge
watching session with the fastest man
alive this week hell yeah part two of
kite man's origin story takes flight and
a new issue of Batman both The Dark
Knight and the Joker pressured kite man
to join the respective causes and
Charles Brown finally snaps and begins
its descent into the criminal underworld
Tom King is breathing new life into one
of Batman's most obscure enemies so
don't miss the making of a super villain
an issue number 30 starting today Kubo
an diehard Oliver Queen fans are gonna
lose their mind when they see the
reunion that's in this week's Green
Arrow the Emerald Archer has teamed up
with the Justice League's finest to stop
the ninth circle but now his mission is
taking him into space and only Green
Lantern can get him there find out how
Ollie and Hal repair their relationship
in issue number 30 starting today
DC and hanna-barbera are opening a new
chapter in their partnership with
dastardly and muttley
after the citizens of unlike last and
accidentally pump a dangerous
radioactive element into the atmosphere
it's up to Colonel dick and Captain mutt
to stop an atomic catastrophe brush up
on your nuclear codes and check out
issue number one this week DC's world's
finest subscription service gives you an
exclusive set of clothes collectibles
and more every quarter and we're
cracking open the very first box to get
it all that Batman goodness inside
alright y'all let's open up this bad boy
enough talk talk is cheap
boom world's finest collection Wayne
Enterprises
the batman box okay here we go first up
right off the bat and I did dude that
pun on purpose a Batman vinyl figure it
world's finest exclusive where he's
wearing his a DC rebirth costumes you
can see right there so that's pretty
awesome we're gonna put that right there
then next up we've got a mug this is a I
see very clever it's a smoke grenade
travel mug look at that it's just like
the bat bat bat classic Batman smoke
grenade right there so that's awesome
very nice quality put that right there
oh we got a very nicely folded up
t-shirt who folded up that t-shirt good
job look at this what is this a Wayne
Industries that is amazing
check it out you guys can go to Gotham
City put this on walk right in then I'm
gonna say nothing okay next up what is
this thing right here look at this
it's a utility card with a bunch of
different stuff on it it's got like a
ruler and a little bottle opener what is
this thing Oh multi-purpose utility tool
you've got a knife edge a screwdriver a
can opener up position for position
wrench what that's awesome okay cool
we're gonna put this bad boy away right
there here we go slide that in and
there's your utility tool and then next
we have this what the heck is this thing
this is not a toy that's important to
note and these are all okay
Batarang pushpins look at this very cool
Wow
you can eat corn like The Dark Knight Oh
delicious mmm
that's awesome okay cool we got those
pushpins very nice addition to any
kitchen I'm sure oh look at this this is
the thing I'm probably the most excited
about it is a grappling hook umbrella
you guys I'm not gonna open this indoors
because it's bad luck and I'm very
superstitious I'm a superstitious and
cowardly lot but look at that that is a
great classic grappling hook oh that's
so cool all right can't wait to use that
when it starts to rain okay what we have
here
okay don't eat that throw that away but
don't eat it oh look at these we have
some some Police Department GCPD files
that stands for Gotham City Police
Department duh top secret it looks like
just right off the bat right off the bat
it looks like I've got Joker and
two-face and this comes with a cool
bloody Joker card
wait what's his real name unknown ah
I thought I was gonna get the answers in
the box okay real name Harvey Dent aka
two-face I bet you the other side of
this thing is all scratched up I want to
see the evidence now this kids this is a
very bad thing to do I am tampering with
evidence right here I just ruined any
investigation yeah look at that oh
that's cool let's see you live heads
tails you die oh you guys are dead cool
I killed you all right there we go
put those right there who we got some
nice little iron on patches Wayne
industries that use sweet logo with the
cool yellow trim around it very nice
very nice and lastly we've got a
beautiful gorgeous little mini poster
this is obviously David Finch artwork
that's gorgeous look at that again
perfect for wintertime oh man the frame
that bad boy and then you're all set the
deadline for the Batman box has passed
but we can reveal that the next box is
Justice League themed so make sure you
sign up right now at world's finest
collection comm panels of the week in
mirror are closer than they appear
before we go we've got a world's finest
batman box and we're giving one away to
a lucky fan for your chance to win has
the DC Comics dot-com / watch and win
fill out the form with all your
information it is so easy even your
neighbor who can't tie their shoes could
do it absolutely and attention all
cosplayers we're organizing a meetup at
New York Comic Con for everybody dressed
up as one of the evil Batman from Dark
Knight's
metal so start getting your dark
multiverse cosplay ready and stay tuned
for more details closer to the con see
you tomorrow bye